salut c'est le second faisait quelques
jours j'étais à madrid vous emmener avec
moi pour découvrir le chien au mime il
ya deux nids à 2 light aujourd'hui on va
faire le test du chiot mimi a deux qui
est juste prix cif
on va l'ouvrir on va le boxer on va
regarder comment et fat la boîte on va
regarder si on prise en main les
couleurs ça j'ai déjà pris en main à
madrid ont déjà bull dire il est plutôt
pas mal et puis surtout surtout et
surtout la promesse est faite un schumi
là dessus c'est la photo de la photo en
faible luminosité on va regarder si la
prom est au rendez vous si ce chien ou
au miel de heillecourt oui ou non et on
y va
forcément la première chose à faire
quand on parle d'un test de smartphones
c'est bien évidemment de l'ouvrir
on va à voilà déjà digérer tout ça voilà
donc la boîte du mit à deux boîtes très
simple plutôt joli à l'avant ça change
un peu de cédric klapisch et omis ça
c'est quand même beaucoup plus graphique
beaucoup plus joli il tourne sous
android one des concours
on a accès directement à ça à
l'intérieur nous avons un petit guide
d'utilisation assez standard chez chuo
me faut bosser plutôt pas mal et puis
les constructeurs ont plutôt tendance à
ne plus les maîtres donc ça c'est plutôt
un point positif nous avons aussi notre
adaptateur usb type ses portes jacques
ce qui vous a forcément là dessus il n'y
a pas deux prises jack nous avons ici
une coque transparente du plus bel effet
et ici le smartphone qui se dévoile
on a déjà pu voir qu'on a déjà pu
prendre en main directement un madrid
ici un câble usb usb type c'est votre
adaptateur secteur et voilà je crois
qu'on a fait le tour de la question
sadique vous l'ouvrez s'est mis en avant
et tourne sous android one
d'un point de vue purement esthétique il
est basique et les classiques vous avez
des coins arrondis ici en écran de 5,99
pouces format 18/9 c'est une résolution
de 2160 par 1080 pixels c'est du fjd
plus 403 des pays avec un écran quelque
85% de la face avant des bordures sur le
haut sur le bas si vous voulez une
encoche il faut aller sur le mit à 2
light ce côté saint-jean classiques
boutons de volume ici bouton pour
l'allumer et l'éteindre là en dessous
vous avez de l'usb type c'est un haut
parleur mono gens voulaient jouer son
côté statique pendant le même design
d'un côté comme de l'autre mais là
dessus il ya quarante parleur mono son
côté tiroirs de cartes sim pour loger
jusqu'à deux cartes sim ici de
l'infrarouge peu utilisé comme une
télécommande à l'arrière capteur
d'empreintes digitales ici logoté ni
android one la certification c'est eux
alors la spécificité de smartphones se
situe au niveau des caméras et si vous
avez une double caméra 12 mégapixels
plus 20 mégapixels
ce sont tous deux des capteurs sony l'a
12 mégapixels comme la 20 mégapixels en
ouverture de f 1.75 donc donné comme
étant vraiment performante en faible
luminosité à l'avant vous avez un
capteur de 20 méga pixels avec une
ouverture de f/2
points 2 ils déverrouille très
rapidement vous posez votre doigt il
reconnaît tout de suite en termes de
performances ça fonctionne on a un
snapdragon 660 couplé à 4 gigas dame la
puce graphique c'est une qualcomm adreno
512 lors des phases de test sur
différentes utilisations y répond
franchement bien j'ai pas de souci je
trouve que par contre les choses un peu
lorsqu'on va un peu le solliciter ce
volume est déjà un petit peu gourmand il
a tendance à chauffer ça peut être son
défaut est là résultats seront tous 219
1822 c'est pas mal à apprendre sur la
série 600 en des qualcomm snapdragon
on n'est pas sur la série 800 néanmoins
pour utilisation standard ça fonctionne
il est dispo soit en 4 gigas de ram 32
go de stockage soit 4 gigas de ram 64
giga de stockage soit 6 giga de ram 128
go de stockage le pont soit gardé sur
son smartphone en termes de stockage
c'est l'absence de carte microsd
si vous l'achetez en 128 giga vous
aurait pas de problème dans 64 gigas je
pense que ça fera aussi la terre par
contre en 32 gigas vous risquez tout de
suite de manque un petit peu de place ça
peut être un petit peu handicapant quand
autonomie on a une batterie de 3000
millions terreur est à noter que vous
avez également du bluetooth 5.0
maintenant la promesse qui est vraiment
faite là-dessus par cheyrou oui c'est
vraiment la photo et la vidéo en faible
luminosité
et là-dessus cherche très clairement à
se positionner et face à samsung et
notamment face au galaxy à 8 donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va le tester
en conditions du réel
on va aller dehors ça tombe bien
justement une soirée on va aller faire
des photos des vidéos et on va dire
aussi tout ça par la suite on va
regarder si c'est intéressant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'est du capteur arrière là forcément
c'est la nuit j'ai vraiment attendu la
nuit là il est chose comme une heure et
demie du match retour de resto jeu c'est
forcément les temps tous très très
fatiguée mais pour se rendre compte
d'une caméra qui est plutôt lumineuse
fonctionne bien la nuit mais il faut
attendre la nuit donc là une heure et
demie du match on y est dites moi vous
ce que vous en pensez ce que l'image
vous paraît correct oui non bon
maintenant à regarder du côté de la
caméra havre voilà maintenant un petit
peu du côté de la caméra de celle qui je
vais faire le point sur moi pas là comme
ça voir si ça fonctionne nous dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez il faut
puissant commentaires je me vois
forcément il ya quand même pas mal de
bruit sur l'image notamment au niveau du
visage il ya quand même pas mal de bruit
sur le mur à l'arrière la caméra fait la
faire par contact du point de vu de la
faible et visiter sur la photo la vidéo
c'est quand même moins c'est bon il faut
savoir combien de chiots me a axé sa
communication autour de picture perfect
d'un mégapixels caméra ça c'est le
communiqué de presse
alors je suis d'accord et pas d'accord
c'est à dire que lorsque les conditions
de lumière sont vraiment optimale c'est
vrai que la caméra est superbe a su
l'aréna diard sauf que cet appareil il
est bien lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
soleil lorsque vous avez beaucoup de
lumière lorsque vous êtes vraiment
faible luminosité
ça reste quand même son point faible bon
là de ce que je vais en tout cas sur la
caméra de ses filles je suppose un petit
peu à contre jour ça fait exprès on va
quand même pas trop mal les détails la
lumière lâche un peu sur exposé mais
notre côté il ya le soleil l'a
directement en pleine tronche et il est
quelque chose comme midi et quelques
mais bon ça allait enfin faire pour
déjouer ces quads et tu mets l'attesté
la caméra du téléphone c'est quoi ton
dinosaures pas mal quand on voit que des
caisses comme les autres
c'est normal le résultat quand même le
rendu est vraiment top
les domaines vraiment d'excellente
qualité il ya du hdr ça marche bien les
couleurs sont là elles sont contrastées
c'est vraiment équilibré le rendu est
vraiment bien donc ce ce point de vue là
c'est vrai que il fait vraiment le job
maintenant dès qu'il ya plus lumière des
contacts de suite en faible luminosité
c'est pas ça et pourtant c'est vraiment
ce qui avait été mis en avant par xiaomi
c'est-à-dire un smartphone qui est
capable de faire d'excellentes photos et
par extension vidéo en faible luminosité
grâce à deux capteurs ici avec une
ouverture de f 1.75 sauf que en réalité
est que réduite une expérience plutôt
intéressante en terme de photos et
vidéos faible luminosité et le résultat
est vraiment n'est vraiment pas terrible
beaucoup de bruit sur l'image un rendu
qui est vraiment loin d'être qualitatif
bien évidemment l'ouverture ne fait pas
tout vous avez deux capteurs saunier
l'arrière pour 12 mégapixels si annie
amics 486 et pour le vin mégapixels ci
est liée à mx 376 sur la caméra de saïfi
à l'avant on est une des médias pixels
sa dynamique 376 actions d'arthur de f
2.2 là forcément on lui en voudrait un
peu moins mais c'est vrai qu'en faible
luminosité
je trouve que le rendu est pas géniale
sur les photons selphy vous avez le mode
beauty fayez k tendance un petit peu
trop alice et lorsque vous allez passer
sur le but qu'ils faillent level 5
il a vraiment tendance à trop lisse et
les visages on perd un petit peu
l'aspect naturel
bon après voilà ça c est en faut pour
tous les goûts il y en a qui vont aimer
avoir une peau extrêmement lisse avec un
rendu qui est vraiment loin du naturel
il y en a qui préférent ont dû beaucoup
plus naturelle ce qui est mon cas
bon ça il en faut pour tout le monde
force que la qualité de l'écran est pas
mal ça fonctionne bien vous pouvez
forcément agrandir votre image comme ça
sa croupe est un petit peu même ordre à
l'absolu c'est pas extrêmement grave
maintenant du point de vue de l'oeil aux
francos si le son est pas mal belmonte à
fond vous allez voir
[Applaudissements]
les haut parleurs trouve ici c'est juste
une petite grille pour avoir une
symétrie pas que ce soit plus jolie
leçon et bien franchement fonctionne la
puissance à dessus ça crache c'est pas
mal après sur la prise en otage de
trouve bien ça c'est économique le droit
trouve très facilement car pendant tant
de digital ici bon c'est un grand
classique car une fois de plus on a
accès aux boutons là le bouton pour
allumer pour l'éteindre
côté positif sur ce smartphone c'est
qu'il est effectivement pas très épais
pas de port jack probablement pour
gagner en épaisseur
dans l'absolu je trouve que ça un
produit quand même plutôt bien fini
attention néanmoins ici vous avez quand
même le module caméra qui est un peu pro
est imminent lorsque vous le faisait
voyez il est un peu bancal soyez pas
trop frotter et que ça risque pas à
force de vous endormir et cette partie
dont je vous conseille fortement plus
plus plus plus plus de mettre une coque
de protection autour votre smartphone
autre point positif de ce smartphone ce
qui tourne sous android one il ya plein
de personnes qui n'aimait pas du tout
mis 8 qui n'est d'ailleurs toujours pas
mis lui qu'il reproche de ressemble un
peu trop à ios
la proue son druide one vous êtes sur un
android pur dur ça marche c'est bien ça
les amoureux d'android vont vraiment
apprécier
bon là dessus vous le savez on est sur
un smartphone milieu de gamme
lormontaise n'ai pas senti de latence
particulière pas de problème particulier
je vous dis le seul petit point négatif
que j'aurais au niveau du smartphone en
lui même au niveau tout cas de la
performance c'est le fait qu'il va
chauffer un petit peu lorsque vous avez
tapé dans des applications peu trop
gourmande dans des jeux un peu gourmand
à la longue il va chauffer et c'est pas
forcément hyper agréable
une fois de plus on est sur un
snapdragon 660 on n'est pas sur 1 845 on
est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme
n'est pas sur un smartphone haut de
gamme
donc il faut savoir raison garder pas
forcément utiliser des jeux qui vont
être trop moment à côté de ça je trouve
plutôt équilibré pour utilisation
standard c'est-à-dire photos réseaux
sociaux email
vidéo enfin vidéos regardées des lettres
flix des youtube
tout ce que vous voulez sort sur
internet de ce côté là il est top il est
vraiment bien et le deuxième point
négatif que j'ai vraiment reprocher à ce
smartphone et c'est pourtant ce qui est
donné un petit peu dans l'adn de ce
produit c'est la faute aux fameux
luminosité je le redis une fois de plus
la photo lorsque vous avez des
conditions optimales vous regretterez
pas il est vraiment super par contre
lorsque vous allez à beaucoup lu
alors une fois de plus on n'est pas sur
un pépin pro on n'est pas sur un galaxy
s 9 plus on n'est pas serein iphone 10
on n'est pas sur un mille 8008 explorer
qu'on n'est pas sur un mix 2 on est sur
le mit adopte donc on va pas non plus
lui demander la lune
par contre c'est un petit peu le focus
qui a été fait par xiaoming su je serais
heureux j'aurais peut-être ghz et un
autre pour un terme de communiqué mais
malgré tout ce smartphone reste un
excellent smartphone est globalement il
est pas trop cher je vous déconseille
fortement la version 32 gigas parce qu'à
un moment vous allez manquer d'espacé de
stockage la version en 32 gigas coup 269
avec 90 euros d'ailleurs j'ai des amis
des liens vers description si vous
intéresse alors création 64 giga coup
299,90 euros on a donc 30 euros d'écart
et croyez moi pour 30 euros d'écart ça
vous le colonisé sur le double de
stockage en 64 gigas après je suis pas
convaincu qu'il faille aller sur le 128
giga il a été annoncé par xiaomi à 349
euros à mon avis on va le trou dans le
commerce un petit peu plus cher vous
entourent les 369 euros
à mon avis avec ce prix là à ce prix là
vous retrouver des produits peut-être
plus intéressant chez omis bon bilan des
courses faut-il acheter se mit à 2-2
xiaomi j'ai tendance à dire que s'il
design vous plaît si vous n'êtes pas
trop regardant au niveau des photos en
faible luminosité et si vous n'êtes pas
un gamer habitait alors je sais vous
allez me dire sur les gamers je voyais
su on va jouer sur un pc ou alors on va
jouer peut-être sur en réseau fon ou sur
le black shark de chiots me why not donc
si vous n'êtes pas un gamer invétéré si
vous n'êtes pas trop gros ou trop
gourmande
ce smartphone pc pour vous mais je
trouve que le design sans être
révolutionnaire et franchement dans
l'air du temps c'est un basique
aujourd'hui légèrement arrondi sur les
côtés le double module photo à la
verticale qui arrivé l'année dernière
avec l'iphone disent pourquoi pas le
fait de ne pas avoir dans koch peut
aussi très intéressant a contrario le
miel de light à une encoche l'écran et
bien il est lumineux lorsque je pousse
la luminosité à fond ça fait là faire ça
marche très bien l'audio fonctionne bien
haut parleur mono mais qui est puissant
pour moi se mit à 2 est un bon
smartphone dans le milieu de gamme est
en tout cas on sent sexy omi a vraiment
à coeur de faire des produits de bonne
qualité pour positionner sur un marché
arrivé à des tarifs toujours plus
agressif et avec ce milieu de light le
pari est remplie qui clôt ce que vous en
pensez vous un commentaire est ce que ce
miel
vous intéresser est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter est-ce que vous avez
déjà 22,6 romy et est ce que au final
vous pouvez y ait succombé à la
tentation du mit à deux vous ne marquez
tout ça bien évidemment aux commentaires
connecté avec vous ils y retrouvent au
message essayer d'y répondre
j'en remercie inde est toujours plus
nombreuses ce jour plus nombreux
j'espère apporter un peu de l'etec
partent en vacances on est aujourd'hui
le le dimanche 29 juillet font tout pour
la vidéo et j'avais publié le lundi 30
juillet que vous la regardiez un juif
verdier redoutant cette femme automne en
baissant pas mort j'espère vous allez
bien que vous vous éclatez puis vous
décrivez vous marquez des sur toutes vos
questions suggestions des interrogations
directement commentaires je vous dis à
très bientôt je vous embrasse n'oubliez
pas vous aider meilleur temps
[Musique]